Congress passed a temporary spending
bill to keep the government open on the
eve of Donald Trump's 100th day in
office the one-week stopgap bill would
allow lawmakers to work out a way to
keep the government funded until
September 30th the end of the fiscal
year President Trump has downplayed the
significance of the 100-day milestone
but he says he believes the early days
of hidden his administration have been
just about the most successful in the
nation's history
here's Errol Barnett after signing one
of the 31 executive orders of his
presidency on Friday this one aimed at
opening up offshore oil drilling
development President Trump
weighed in on the importance of the
100-day benchmark in say false standard
100 days but I have to tell you I don't
think anybody has done what we've been
able to do in 100 days so we're very
happy but as a candidate Donald Trump
laid out an aggressive 28.9 plan for his
first 100 days totally renegotiate NAFTA
repeal and replace Obamacare we're going
to end Common Core the president has
fulfilled or moved on about half of the
executive promises in the contract
including suspending immigration from
what he calls terror prone regions but
the president's two attempts at a travel
ban are currently blocked by federal
courts nominating Supreme Court justice
Neel Gorsuch and this week introducing
an overhaul of the tax code under the
Trump plan we will have a massive tax
cut for businesses and massive tax
reform in simplification still the
president has not sent to Congress any
of the 10 bills the contract outlines
mr. Trump flex the nation's military
muscle this month when he ordered a
cruise missile strike on Syria after
Bashar al-assad's regime used chemical
weapons against civilians believe in
yourselves believe in your future and
believe once more in America the
president was widely praised for his
first address to Congress in February
but controversy quickly followed in a
series of tweets four days later
Trump accuse President Barack Obama of
wiretapping Trump Tower during the
campaign a charge dismissed by FBI
director James Comey with respect to the
president's tweets about alleged
wiretapping directed at him by the prior
administration I have no information
that supports those tweets in that same
hearing before a congressional panel
investigating alleged ties between the
Trump campaign and the Russian
government Comey acknowledged a separate
FBI investigation into the Trump
campaign as an eventful first 100 days
comes to a close the president is also
reflecting on his new job in an
interview with Reuters he said he
expected the work of the President to be
easier on Fox News Friday night he was
asked whether a second White House bid
is in the cards do you ever think well
maybe one term would be enough of this
kind of life well I mean I want to see
how we're doing
but I've always said it's going to be
eight years not four years for CBS this
morning Saturday Errol Barnett
Washington